I have a question about the lymphatic system
and like, and all the detoxing.
I mean, I guess with everything that we're doing,
like I'm doing the infrared sauna and then the rife
and then the food and the juicing and animals.
So a lot of detoxing.
So I get bouts of fatigue, you know,
overall I feel good and then I'll get bouts of fatigue.
And then when I was at my functional doctor
on the bio resonance machine, it showed my lymphatic
was sluggish.
I jump on the trampoline.
So my question is, can the detox, of course,
make us fatigued and can it slug up the lymphatic system?
Slug up the lymphatic system.
Good question.
All right.
So what is detoxification?
So detoxification is getting bad things out of your body
that we don't want to their body, right?
So where are these bad things that we're trying to get out
of the body?
So every day detox is what's taking place.
So let's take a step back.
In a perfect world, you're exposed to different toxins.
So even 300 years ago, you're exposed to toxins.
Maybe not the same ones that we were exposed to now.
There was no mud, santo, there was no fertilizer,
there were no chemical spread out fields.
But there was coal burned for heat all the time.
So there was a lot of byproducts of coal.
In the air, you look at old pictures of cities
and they're black in the city, the bricks
of the building were black and such
because coal was burned everywhere.
There were other toxins that they were exposed to.
Not maybe so many harmful chemicals,
but there was exposure to a lot of different toxins.
That being said, it is imperative that your body is detoxifying.
So if you breathe that coal dust in,
it went into your bloodstream and into your bloodstream,
then it went through the liver.
And it went through that phase one, phase two,
phase two point five, dumped into the bile duct,
dumped into the small attested, dumped into the toilet.
And as long as my those pathways were ample enough
to deal with the amount of toxic exposure,
I never became toxic because you aren't what you eat,
you aren't what you absorb,
you are what you don't get rid of.
So as long as I was on a daily or weekly basis,
getting rid of all the things that I was exposed to,
then those things never stated my system,
and I never became quote unquote toxic.
That is why there were less amounts of cancer
back 300 years ago.
And if you took out the factor of birth death set birth,
a death, death set early age,
or death's below the age of sex,
people were living just as long 300 years ago as they are now.
So don't buy this if you're getting more cancer
because people are living longer, because that's not true.
So if you're getting rid of everything
that you're exposed to on a weekly basis,
then you're not getting them, you're not toxic.
Well, what do you mean?
How would I be toxic?
Well, if I'm not getting rid of everything
that I've been exposed to on a weekly basis,
these toxins circulate through the blood,
and I will either die or my body will shunt these toxins to my cells.
And that's what happens.
So toxins are not getting through the pathways
because we're exposed to it overabundance of them,
or the pathways aren't working correctly.
So the toxins are shunted to a cell,
and then those cells store toxins, heavy metals,
poisons, chemicals, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
So all these chemicals that we're exposed to
are settled in the cells.
That's how cancer starts.
So 99% of the time, they don't cause cancer,
and I could live to 120 years old and die,
and then have somebody cut open a slice of my body,
smear a cell slice onto a slide,
and look at it under a microscope.
Electrodbiker's scope would say,
wow, look at all these hydrocarbons.
Look at that benzene that's in that cell.
Look at the mercury, look at the lead.
Oh my gosh, this guy was full of toxins.
But as long as it didn't interrupt any of the metabolic pathways,
it didn't cause disease.
Problem is it interrupts the metabolic pathways a lot.
And if it interrupts the metabolic pathway
in the nucleus of the cell that is essential for cell replication,
that's what's called cancer.
So if mercury in my cell interrupts my cell replication cycle,
it's caused cancer.
So we need to detox.
Well, how do we detox?
Well, we have to improve phase one, phase two,
phase two point five, phase three detoxification pathways.
And we do things like everything that I have you guys doing
that will also help my cells push stuff back into the blood
so it could detox.
Now, my cells aren't always going to push things back into the blood.
They're going to push things outside of the cell membrane.
So, membros cells are this little round thing
that has membrane around it.
And when we're getting rid of the toxins in that cell,
it pushes it outside of that cell,
outside through the cell membrane,
into the space called the extracellular space.
That's the space between the cells.
The extracellular space is a fluid matrix
with proteins and a bunch of junk that the cells just gave off
because they're trying to clean themselves out.
And then that extracellular space is drained
by an open-ended capillary system called your lymph system,
which you can think of as a storm sewer.
So, your cells are like houses
that are throwing the garbage out into the street.
And now the garbage has to be cleaned up and take it away.
Otherwise, we just have a whole bunch of garbage
sitting at our street, aka the extracellular spaces.
And that doesn't make us feel good.
So, we could get a sick feeling,
tired, sluggish, not feeling well,
because we are detoxied very well.
The cells, but we're dumping it into the extracellular space.
And if we have an overabundance that our lymphatics
are draining well, then we could have sluggish feeling dead.
And we could also have sluggish feeling
if our lymphatics are working,
but it's getting back to the liver.
And phase one, phase two, phase two point five
isn't working well, and we've talked about that a lot.
That's why we use things like milk, thistle,
and nerve two accelerator, and keep what accelerator,
and pond what assist, and detox accelerator,
and phosphatinal coli, colleted, subbitters, and binders.
That's why we're doing all that stuff.
So, you've got to look down the line.
Is it a problem with the liver cell itself?
Is it a problem with the liver getting it into the bile?
Let's look a little farther back.
Is it a problem with the lymphatic system
being able to pick it up?
Is it a problem with the toxins that are getting it
in the lymphatic system, but it's not getting back to the blood?
Well, how does the lymphatic system work?
Well, the lymphatic system works by contraction of the muscle.
So, if all were to a city around on the couch,
eating healthy bond buds, we're still not going to detox very well
because we're not getting lymphatic drainage
and lymphatic movement.
But you said, I'm doing the sauna.
I'm doing the cheetah sheet.
I'm doing skin brushing.
I'm doing exercise and I'm contracting muscles.
But I'm feeling sluggish.
You could be doing everything right
in the symptoms that you might be getting there
because you're really doing a good job
of cellular detoxification.
And it's, you're kind of overwhelmed with the liver,
but you're doing everything right.
And this too shall pass.
And you kind of got to go through that a little bit too.
So, you might think about a couple things.
Well, I've been doing this for a couple of months
and I'm still getting sluggish.
You could slow down on some of those things
and just take it easy.
And maybe you're going too fast and overwhelming your liver.
It's not that we need to support the liver anymore.
We're just going too fast and overwhelming
and see if that makes a difference.
But you've got to look back at all the pathways that go
whereby maybe overdue it.
But where do I need some support?
Maybe I don't need any support.
I just need to drink some water and cool off for a little bit.
Try some of those things.
OK, thank you.
That's very good.